[Music]
the holiday season
is a time to celebrate and to be around
loved ones
but this year everything from christmas
markets to family gatherings
is having to be scaled back due to the
kovid19 pandemic
social distancing and other restrictions
have left
many feeling less than festive so what
should a good covet christmas look like
this is dw's covid19 special i'm janelle
de malaon
as germany grapples with yet another
record number in coronavirus cases it's
weighing up how best to allow for
merrymaking
while keeping the virus from spreading
and all across europe
it's a similar picture people are
breaking with tradition
as they change their plans to
accommodate restrictions
here in the spanish city of sevilla the
christmas lights that you see behind me
stay off at the moment even at night the
city administration is afraid of big
crowds
that might come and watch them the
general restrictions for christmas here
in spain are not clear yet
but everybody knows this will be a very
different festive season
even in my own family which is partly
german and partly spanish
we don't know what to do yet and if we
will be able to meet each other
at all normally at this time of year the
place behind me would look totally
different
there would be lots of christmas market
stands and the smell of roasted almonds
everywhere to get you in the mood
but what i personally miss the most this
december
is meeting friends in the evening and
drinking mulled wine together
the only thing that cheers me up this
year is mild wine to go
cheers and merry christmas now how to
strike a balance between
necessary interpersonal contact and the
required social distancing
is a big question for many of us as the
christmas holidays get closer
here to help us understand this better
is tegan crews she is an associate
professor and clinical psychologist
at the australian national university
thank you very much for joining us tegan
now according to your research our risk
perception during an encounter with a
person depends on how well we know them
why is it that people find it so hard to
take the necessary coveted precautions
with the people we love
it's something we've been looking at for
a number of years in our research group
and one thing that we've found is that
there's this consistent relationship
where people are much more willing to
take
risks with the people that they are
closest to they're ones that they love
um and that seems to be because we
humans are
hardwired to use that sense of social
connection we have to others
the groups that we belong to and the
communities that we value
we use that as a cue to safety uh it's a
signal that we can trust someone and
that they are a safe person for us to
you know put our life in their hands and
in some ways that makes a lot of sense
you know if you're looking for someone
to take care of your children
your closest networks probably are the
people you can trust the most
on the other hand when it comes to the
spread of a contagious disease
it doesn't make a lot of sense and so i
think that's what we're seeing here is
that our instincts to trust those that
are closest to us are actually
undermining our safety when it comes to
covert 19.
our hard-wired instincts putting putting
us at risk of that can be quite
quite a problem but can you tell us
again how did you come to these
conclusions
yeah we've been conducting a series of
studies over a number of years
um including before covett so we were we
were interested in this
um over the last few years and ran a few
studies looking at risk perception
but we've also looked at it since the
the pandemic began
um and one nice opportunity we had to do
that was a study
that we had running at the beginning of
march we were looking at neighborhoods
and people's connection to their
community
and the original intention was to look
at uh people's sort of uh participation
in community events but um
when the pandemic really gained steam in
march
we changed the the purpose of one
particular project in order to look at
uh how this particular research question
around the link between
our group memberships the trust we have
in others and our risk perception
and what we found was that in our sample
of a couple of hundred people in
australia
um the the stronger that people
identified with their local neighborhood
and their community
um before covert so in early march the
more likely they were to trust their
neighbours
in lockdown which sounds like a great
thing but the problem
in this case with trusting one's
neighbors was that that also predicted
that they were
more comfortable being in close contact
with those neighbors so breaching
physical distancing recommendations for
instance and
spending time in in the physical
presence of their neighbours
felt safer because they had that trust
in their neighbours
so so that would be an example of one of
the studies we've run looking at this
link
where social connection and the sense of
belonging we have with others which is
usually such a protective and positive
thing
can actually undermine our capacity to
respond to a pandemic
of this nature indeed and if social
contact is
needed to stay healthy but at the same
time it puts us at risk
what are we to do then
it is a bit of a catch-22 i think
because i certainly wouldn't want to say
that social connection
isn't important i think it's one of the
most important things when it comes to
protecting our health and indeed our
mental health
over the long term and it's also the
case that people who are
most vulnerable to covert 19
complications are often the same people
who are vulnerable to loneliness
uh to isolation and to the poor health
consequences that we see as a result of
that
um one of the things i think that 2020
has really necessitated for all of us is
to be creative
about how we stay connected to one
another um whether that's through using
virtual means in ways that we might
not have considered prior to this year
or whether it's you know choosing to get
together
outside or in a socially distanced more
safe way of getting together and seeing
our closest contacts i think we need to
find compromises that allow us to stay
connected
while taking as fewer risks as possible
when it comes to covert
you've written that the critical role of
shared identity
and therefore of higher risk taking has
been under recognized in public health
messaging
how exactly should public health
messages change in your opinion
i think that there has perhaps hasn't
been much attention to the to the
difference between
the risks we're willing to take with
strangers on public transport out in our
communities
versus the risks we're willing to take
within our closest networks with our
families and with our friends
and the problem with that is that we're
actually very very ready to accept the
risk of strangers
but much less ready to recognize and
accept the risk in our closest networks
um and in fact that's exactly exactly
where the vast majority of covert
transmission is happening it's happening
in households it's happening
at small gatherings of family and
friends so i think
ideally i'd like to see public health
messaging really be a bit more focused
on how we can
reduce those risks in our closest
networks and how we can celebrate
important milestones like birthdays and
christmas
without putting the people we love in
danger
so social distancing protecting the
people you love thank you very much that
was teagan crewish she is an associate
professor and clinical psychologist
at the australian national university
thank you for your time and insights
today
thanks janelle and for the final time
this week
our science correspondent derek williams
answers one of your questions
for a 20 year old what's the risk of
taking the vaccine compared to not
taking it
most of the questions i'm getting at the
moment involve potential
vaccines and and this one is close to
the top of the list
the experts i've read who discussed this
topic
make several important points first of
all they say
you should look at the numbers that we
have so far
like the data showing that for tens of
thousands of people
in three big vaccine trials there have
been no reported
serious side effects although bear in
mind
that those test subjects didn't have
known
pre-existing health problems for people
who do
there could be more risk involved we
just heard for example about a couple of
cases of people
in the uk who had pre-existing allergies
having a bad reaction to one vaccine but
the experts still say
that the potential risks are pale in
comparison to the risks
involved in catching the virus sure
a 20 year old is a lot less likely to
die from covet 19
than an 80 year old is but but some do
why take that chance if we have
something
that medical authorities say can safely
protect you
which brings me to point two even if a
young person is much less likely
to die from the disease there's also a
chance
that a covet-19 infection could cause
long-term health issues by some
estimates
up to a third of those who who recover
continue to have
more chronic complaints that that
doesn't seem to be age dependent
so so young people have them too
point number three getting vaccinated
also
has a social aspect which is that it
could potentially help protect the
people around you
though that question granted is still up
in the air still
expectations are high that if vaccines
stop people from developing fully
fledged covet 19
they'll also help cut down on
transmission and and that'll slow down
the pandemic
for all of us um finally don't forget
that young people who aren't in
essential jobs will be pretty
far down on the list for vaccination in
most countries
by the time most of them can get a shot
we're going to have a lot more
information about
any potential serious side effects but
based on what we know now
most experts expect those to be very
[Music]
rare
you